welcome back to New rockstars I'm Anna
vanson and as faithful as the Super
Mario Brothers movie was to the game
series there were a few changes that
took me off guard as someone who knows
frankly too much about the games the
desire to push my metaphorical glasses
up was through the roof but we're not
going to because the Mario movie
universe and the game Mario Universe are
decidedly different as we're about to
demonstrate we're not even gonna get
into the comics because honestly I just
can't today but let's take a look at
some of the changes they made between
the two universes and heads up I'm
saving the most controversial one for
last when we were breaking down the
trailers and first saw the shot of
Bowser standing over a star exclaiming
that he found it we hypothesized that
this might be the last power star out of
six that Bowser was collecting to become
all-powerful after all aside from the
grand star in Every Mario game where
Stars show up there are so many of them
sometimes hundreds this theory was then
backed by there being six kingdoms six
stars around Peach's Castle stars around
the goal pull of the training grounds
the objective in Paper Mario Color
Splash being collect the six stars and
take the Rainbow Road up to Bowser's
Castle it seemed like there was just no
way this could be a regular old Power
Star that gives you invincibility for
like 15 seconds and then
it was and there was only one and Bowser
didn't even use it honestly I have more
questions than answers but in the Mario
movie Universe this is called the
Superstar and it's extraordinarily rare
if not the only one of its kind and
Mario Luigi just used up all 15 seconds
of it whoops and before we continue a
quick reminder to check out nerdrid.shop
where you can always check out the
latest and greatest in new Rockstar's
merch you can make sure you're ready to
travel down any convenient warp pipe
with your very own new Rockstar shirt
and the style of everyone's favorite
hero plumbers it's a great way to
support the channel and help us make
more of these videos that you love shop
all of our great merch options over at
nerd riot.shop so after the first
trailer dropped many people were
wondering where Mario was coming from
when he discovered the Mushroom Kingdom
and it was confirmed that Mario and
Luigi were humans who lived in Brooklyn
which was also their backstory in the
Super Mario Brothers Super Show while
it's been confirmed by Super Mario
Odyssey director Kenta motokura that
Mario is a human and yes there was a
debate around that but we won't get into
it in this video in the game Universe
they seem to have been born in the
Mushroom Kingdom delivered by a stork to
their their parents and even though in
Yoshi's New Island it was shown that in
the first game they were delivered to
the wrong house both the correct house
and the wrong one were mushroom houses
and for being honest those are the same
parents who've switched places not to
mention in Super Mario Odyssey Mario
looks distinctly different from the
residents in New Dong City and when
asked about why that was an official
spokesperson for the company said he's a
Native Son of the Mushroom Kingdom these
just backstory is a lot fuzzier in the
games and you could argue that
everything was shown in the games could
have taken place after the events in the
movie but she's also shown already
walking in the movie when she's crawling
as a baby in the games and there's also
a distinct lack of Toad's worth her
primary caretaker in Mario and Luigi
partners in Time so either way we'll say
her origin shown in the movie are a new
take on the lore so going back to
Yoshi's Island the silhouette of Mario
and Luigi's parents are the only
reference to their family we ever get
when in the movie they have a large
family who are all very close the only
two named family members in the movie
are Uncle Tony and Uncle Arthur and
believe it or not we've heard the name
Uncle Tony before in the Super Mario
Bros Super Show Mario Luigi were
discussing how to cut up a pizza when
Mario says that if Uncle Tony showed up
he would eat more than his share but the
other family members who showed up in
the show consisted of their mom and Aunt
played by Lou Albano and Danny Wells
respectively so there were still some
changes there if you like taking care of
your body you're going to want to fully
tune in because we have one of the best
offers we have ever given on this
channel thanks to geology geology is a
19 time award-winning skin hair and body
care company recognized in men's health
Oprah daily hypebeast Bertie Esquire and
GQ geology creates simple and effective
skin care and Hair Care routines
customized just for you their products
are built around just a handful of
powerful proven ingredients that have
been trusted by dermatologists for
decades just take a quick 30 second
diagnostic quiz and geology will create
a simple and effective skincare hair
care routine customized just for you
geology has got you covered no matter
how you're looking to up your personal
care game but right now they're running
a special offer for a skincare sampler
pack which is great because their skin
care stuff rules geology's line of
skincare products can help you fight
acne reduce oiliness prevent wrinkles
combat darker the under eyes have
smoother hydrated skin and Target signs
of aging personally I'm a fan of their
vitamin C plus e plus ferulic acid serum
but I also use everything else geology
has co-wash for your hair body wash for
your body and deodorant for your odors
whatever you need geology has you
covered there's never been a better time
to try geology even right now for a very
limited time use code new rockstars 100
to get 100 off of your personalized
30-day skincare sample set all you have
to do is cut over the 4.95 for shipping
on top of that new rockstars fans get an
exclusive bonus offer up to 50 off an
additional skin hair and body product of
your choice when you add it to your
trial click the link in the description
or go to g-e-o-l-o-g dot i e slash
rockstars100 to get started in Mario
Odyssey Pauline is the mayor of New donk
City and while it is meant to be settled
after New York the street names are nods
to the Donkey Kong games in the movie
Universe Pauline is the mayor of
Brooklyn as we read from the news
headline that plays in the pizzeria a
title that is unique to the movie in and
of itself since in our world there's a
mayor of New York City but Brooklyn only
has a Borough president but honestly
ruling over these cute cartoon humans in
New York City is probably an upgrade
from those terrifying shells of humans
in new dog City speaking of rulers when
the king of the jungle Kingdom in the
movie was revealed many fans had to do a
double take to realize it was Cranky
Kong and rightfully so since in the
games Cranky Kong is mainly known as a
retired grouchy old man who gives hints
to the Kongs along their Journey not a
king never was a king Never Gonna Be a
King and while there was never an
explanation for how cranky became a king
in the movie I have to imagine it's a
generational inheritance since Donkey
Kong is heir to the throne in the movie
and cranky at least in the game cannon
was the original Donkey Kong in the
arcade game by the way this Paradox led
to an interesting change in the movie in
which the game Jumpman which is clearly
supposed to represent the Donkey Kong
arcade game couldn't have Donkey Kong in
it and in his place is a different
monster possibly a Yeti huh while we're
on the topic Donkey Kong isn't cranky
Kong's son in the games he's his
grandson cranky Kong's son would be
Donkey Kong Jr who had his own game in
which the manual identified the original
Donkey Kong AKA Cranky Kong as Donkey
Kong Jr's Papa which would make the
Donkey Kong in the movie Donkey Kong
Junior's son I know it's confusing but
in the movie Donkey Kong Jr has just
gone from the timeline like Dust in the
Wind and just like the movie we're
moving right now long too let's talk
about the kingdoms and their names in
this movie now the games only have a few
types of lands that are somewhat
consistent throughout the games but to
be honest the lands changed throughout
the games constantly so it would be near
impossible to coherently put all of them
in the movie's various maps and they did
hit the main ones you see in a lot of
the games so that seems like a
reasonable compromise the names of the
places however caught me off guard I was
definitely expecting this place to be
called Donkey Kong Country instead of
the Jungle Kingdom which begs the
question what are they gonna call this
place this is a jungle too can't call it
the jungle Kingdom that's taken they'd
probably call it the Yoshi Kingdom but
if we're basing the names off the
inhabitants then this should really be
called the Kong Kingdom or Donkey Kong
Country but you know what I respect the
kingdom title continuity one smaller but
still important change was the name of
the giant bill that Bowser launched at
the end of the movie he calls it a
bomber bill which is a completely new
name and one that I want to say
because it hurts my soul way less to
invent a new variety of bill with its
own rules then break the rules of an
existing Bill species because this is
most similar to a bonsai bill in the
game to note the eyes open mouth and
lack of arms but Bonsai builds up until
Mario Odyssey moved in a straight line
and they've never been able to just stop
like this so I'm actually really happy
they came up with a new term for this
big guy I have to admit though that it
did throw me off when I saw the green
shells bouncing all around the carts
unscathed in the Rainbow Road portion of
the movie in the games green shells
break upon impact with a cart and in the
movie it hits card after cart with
seemingly no problem I don't have much
to say about that it's just something
they changed and we all have to live
with and it's fine and if you thought I
was gonna talk about the green shells
and not talk about the blue shell
mistaken this is a Hot Topic among fans
and the movie just added fuel to the
fire for those who may be unaware the
spiky winged shell that the Koopa
General turns into in the movie is an
item from the Mario Kart series while
its appearance and movement has changed
throughout the games it has always been
an item that targets first place the
debate revolves around what it's called
colloquially most people call it a blue
shell due to the ease of identifying it
that way but it is officially called a
spiny shell a fact which most team blue
shell people respond to it is simple
nah but why doesn't Nintendo call it a
blue shell it's likely because blue
shells have existed in the game Sans
wings and spikes and they needed to
differentiate them but the movie Bully
proclaimed for the people and called it
a blue shell I have to say though it
doesn't technically settle the debate
since the movie universe is clearly
different from the game universe but
team blue shell can take solace in the
fact that Nintendo really said we see
you with this movie and then team spiny
can take solace in the fact that they're
technically right but only when
referring to the shells in the games on
that note I just want to end by saying
just because there are two different
canons doesn't mean that one is superior
to the other or that everything you knew
from the games is wrong they're two
different universes both are very good
so have civil conversations and just
don't make fun of people in general yeah
let's all metaphorically just live in
the chill Kingdom which is separate from
the snow Kingdom which is only Canon to
the movie meanwhile you can follow me on
Twitter at it's annavanston and follow
And subscribe to new rockstars add new
rockstars for more breakdowns of
everything you love bye
[Music]
thank you